testing testing one two three testes
oh Megan laughing
[Music]
it's a brand new beautiful podcast
studio and we're back and we're back
happy New Year everybody
yeah are we starting
oh we're always are we gonna ask that
question every time let's start uh just
felt false okay so let's do like uh
Happy New Year I hear dead eyes
but you're not believing it because New
Years are they happy or they just
time or they're just new time yeah time
passing I'm I'm feeling very happy yeah
me too I'm feeling good we've been
having fun we have we're here in the um
in this is uh the writer's rooms
of uh It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia
Season 16. we are in the thick of it we
yeah we are under the gun we've got how
many weeks before we start shooting
three no not even no uh 11 to 10 days 10
days 10 work days
[Laughter]
16 days but like yeah like only like 10
work days or something like that well
we're gonna have to dip into the
weekends and late at night you know to
get it done man I've been parking real
close to the pole I hope you've been
satisfied you guys wait okay so this is
good actually it's good that you brought
that up so we're in a parking garage
right now and I am squeezed in between
two so it's a three it's it's like my
car and Charlie there's three spots
there's three spots and then and then
columns right yeah and Charlie's on the
right and Meg's on the left and I'm
squeezed right in the middle so nervous
and I gotta say no listen I I you should
be because I would be very upset but you
guys are just I mean it seems like it
seems to me we're nailing it but it's
only working because you guys are
parking so close to the Colony yeah it
would all be yeah you taught us a little
something about your needs and and
responses and we listen you responded
yeah now is that gonna care now are you
only doing that for me or would you do
that I think that's going to carry on in
my life my poll work will be a little
bit you know more uh professional now
that I know it will uh please someone
yeah yeah
we have a lot of work to do like like we
shouldn't we should not be in this room
right now no what
um but but it's good it's it's nice to
be in here taking a break but man yeah
it's more fun but Megan how are you
coming on your draft most of the day
setting up this time okay that was what
I was worried about
um no I I'm coming along fine um I kind
of skipped past the hardest scene which
is the like setup scene of all of the
stories finding a fun way to do that is
so difficult like actually I noticed it
in this episode that we're talking about
mortgage crisis you found such a fun way
to like get both stories started because
you just did that bit of like d coming
in with her news and you guys all
ignoring her and then Frank coming in
and you immediately being interested in
his news and kind of comparing the two
and thinking maybe we'll combine them
but then ultimately just ditching her
thing which is just like gave it some
energy and so I'm in that scene now and
it's like it's I'm trying to find like a
fun way to get all the information out
that I need to in order to get the story
started which are really fun so I just
started writing the other scenes it is
funny to go to look at these older
episodes and be like wait wait what was
happening in the world like there was
more it was is it was it the 2008
mortgage crisis that we were dealing
with like yeah we shot the episode in
2009 we actually broke the original ver
we broke this story in 2008 for season
four we broke it in season we broke this
we did and yeah so we're talking about
the mortgage credit you want to do the
intro for this episode yeah structure
remember that from last year
um so yeah we're talking we've started
season five today uh the gang exploits
the mortgage crisis it aired on
September 17 2009 it was written by
Becky Mann and Audra seloff and directed
by Randall Einhorn in this episode Frank
buys a foreclosed house with intentions
of selling it for prop profit Mac and
Dennis become hot-headed real estate
brokers and D takes advantage of a
Suburban couple looking to hire a
surrogate mother so yeah that's it we
broke the store in 2008
um in the writer's room of season four
we're Becky and Audra on season four uh
they were I believe I think so I think
it was in season four and then the first
draft they got in was season five is
that right well I remember that I can't
remember why we kicked it I I I don't
know if it was because we
why did we kick that to to season five
do you remember why I don't have just
came up with a thing that we're like
this will be better this season I don't
for whatever reason yeah it's so nice
and so rarely happens we have an extra
episode yeah water park was that yeah
but right yeah yeah going into season
five yeah it was like I remember being
like Oh we have that like mortgage
crisis thing that's like almost I don't
remember what state it was in but I
remember knowing it was an episode it's
just a really good cult I just like
really enjoyed the cold open and it was
when I was writing today I was like I
just need something like that that makes
it like fun to get all that information
out because it is a lot like you gotta
set up all the stuff about like where
now it's only ever go so far right so
we'll be in the room we'll break out
what each scene is going to be but then
how you actually execute the scene yeah
is really what makes the scene work so
there's a version of that cold open
where D comes in spouts her information
Frank does his but without the joke then
what is the scene so you always have to
come up with like well what is the
and it's never easy it's it's yeah
figuring out how to bury the exposition
in what order to pull it out like if
there's if you're getting out all this
information it's like how what order
what's the most effective order yeah
what's necessary in the scene versus
yeah I'm stuck in that on that one but I
just moved ahead to other scenes and
I'll like go back I think to that one
yeah yeah but I'll get it done Thursday
right I have till Thursday
um Thursday morning yeah okay so here's
something here's a fascinating
phenomenon uh that we've that we've just
become accustomed to but usually we
would say oh okay let's let's have the
the script send by Thursday and we
always forget we always forget to say
Thursday morning because if you say
Thursday that's a Friday and rightfully
so people want to do their best and they
want to make sure they have as much time
as they they can we get it but it'll be
Thursday at 11 59 and you'll get
something in your inbox we'll be asleep
because right Rob Roselle will wait
until the absolute lap Megan will get it
in early in the morning that's right
Roselle will get it in there unless we
say Thursday morning the last possible
minute yeah yeah wow and he's
technically correct but we can't work on
it on Thursday right yeah but we can't
work on them all on Thursday anyway
technically we should kind of stagger
them yeah that's not a bad idea that's
why my move is to turn in a draft and
then keep working on it and then turn in
another draft if you guys haven't
started reading Megan that is that's not
a bad move so strange yeah right turning
in your deadline right and if we just
happen to be free and we get to it but
if you don't you're like read this one
instead yes I had the extra time I
wanted yeah why not but if you didn't
and we started you could always walk in
the room and say hey I had these other
ideas yeah yeah if you want to pop it up
yes the thing moving probably though the
fastest draft that I would write would
be the best one because I think that my
drafts become over complicated when I
like
start picking them apart yeah like I
almost think the best version of it is
the thing that I can never do which I
always try to do which is just [ __ ] out
something as fast as possible with like
no attempted jokes like the most basic
what just what is needed for the scene
and then move on and then go back and
like make it kind of funny here and
there we talk about this all the time I
don't know if we've talked about this on
the podcast but
um one Mantra that we've adopted
certainly in Mythic Quest but we talk
about it a lot on this show is just get
it wrong faster and and we all do that
like I we just try to turn it around as
quickly as possible to get it back to
the collective because there is no wrong
and there is no right so the quicker you
can get it back into the process of as
many really funny uh Minds is possible
the the better for the the as long as
you know what matters because like if
you're if you turn in a draft that's
like just a total [ __ ] mess then then
you're creating more work for everybody
right
but if you're Crea if if the story is
working if the characters all have
motivations and everyone's got like an
arc and the story has a good yes but you
have if it's a 24 to 26 page script and
you're a professional writer and it's
already been broken you have and you
have seven days to do it if you spent
all day every day working on that script
there's no there it should not take you
seven days to get there right but most
likely it gets you to three or four and
then you're fine tuning and then the
question becomes when does it become
diminishing returns to where you're
fine-tuning things that won't wind up
structurally even yeah for a listener at
home I mean ideally before we send
someone off on a draft
so much of the work has been done in the
room of outlining that there's enough
there that yes you should be able to
turn around in that much time not to say
that you should be able to write a
script in seven days but like we've done
a lot of work before you go off the
right yeah yeah this episode the
mortgage crisis is a great example of
something that has a lot of
really funny ideas and moments and
scenes and characters and things that
have stood the the test of time people I
hear about Vic Vinegar all the time
and yet I don't I don't think this
episode's very good at all but there's
there's really fun and funny moments in
it well I like about the bird law
conversation that you think it's just
like a classic downbeat of you guys
talking about something that like
doesn't matter at all at the beginning
about whether you can keep a hummingbird
as a pet says the guy who knows nothing
about the law I can absolutely keep a
hummingbird as a pet bro it's no
different than having a parrot or a
parakeet it's a bird you really can't
and I'm not saying I agree with it it's
just that bird law in this country it's
not governed by reason there's no such
thing as Burgers I don't even remember
why why we thought it was like what was
the deal with brother who came up with
that like the idea of like they're being
laws that specifically govern how birds
work or it's hard to remember is it
meant to be is it meant to be like how
what are the laws amongst birds or is it
meant to be like what are the laws
what was funny about it like just like
birds were funny like conversations
about seagulls and hummingbirds and
things that was funny and then and then
like the parameters around like well
there probably are some kind of rules
for you know you're probably not allowed
to keep a bald eagle in your house or
something I I don't know like some birds
would be protected yeah so just feeling
like there was an area of of illegal
expertise that Charlie felt as though he
had some
you know or I felt uh as though I had
some ownership over I guess that was it
I I how can you remember it's so long
ago I ran into Randall Einhorn this year
again Randall Einhorn who directed this
episode and has directed many episodes
yeah but he hasn't directed many in in a
while so maybe his last season was like
eight or something you know and it was
funny to see him and be like wow it's a
long time since I've seen you yeah you
know and yet you know him so well
because what'd you see him do you work
with him no I just bumped at like uh
like a Hollywood function thing no
you're going to Hollywood parties I went
to one you went to pick one no what now
that actually sounds a lot more
interesting than the podcast what kind
of fun what is the Soiree okay but I
have to remember what it was
specifically if it was like Oscars or
Emmys or one of those things where
everyone dresses up uh how dressed up
were you uh medium
it's higher uh yeah right and it was
raining so I remember there was a tent
and I saw Danny there and Danny DeVito
yes I saw a giant movie Randall Einhorn
I saw Paul Walter
who played our Juggalo and he's gone on
to be a great great actor um so you know
I I saw Scott martyr there and I said
come back and write the season he's like
I don't know if I can and then he
proceeded to me to tell me a really
funny story about how his dad had been
ordering this meat and he got this great
deal on this meat and then only like
later like months later for his wife to
realize that he had been ordering dog
food and didn't realize he was he'd been
eating dogs yeah yeah and we're like
this is why we need you back in the
writer's room that's a perfect Frank
story line yeah and he's like I'm back
and then he's not been back but we just
found out today he's back oh really yeah
dog food dog food during the day and cat
food at night is pretty funny yeah there
you go you got to balance it out yeah
they can't eat cat food during the day
I'll put you but I'll tell you what I'll
tell you who's good at those parties is
Mary Elizabeth we went to one of them
and she winds up bumping shoulders
rubbing shoulders with Taylor Swift and
Taylor Swift's like I'm a huge Sunny fan
and uh and and then she's like be in my
music video so not nothing like that
ever happens to me I just speak to
people I already know
you know each other like I assume with
somebody like Taylor Swift I'm like she
does not want to talk to me that's my
assumption that's my sensors she wants
to talk to like you know Leonardo
DiCaprio or somebody she doesn't want to
talk to me yeah yeah yeah you know but
little do I know she she she desperately
wants to talk to me apparently so
anyways
according to that I'm gonna assume next
time I see her that she wants so Taylor
Swift was also at this party that was a
different one oh that was uh sorts of
these I went to two two one
yes I went to the one uh and you don't
remember what either function was about
they were like uh industry-night things
it was either Oscars or Emmys they had
these big old parties and everyone gets
together and I never go I remember
Elizabeth was like you never go to these
why would Taylor Swift go to the Oscars
of the Emmys he doesn't know what his
party was he's just growing up that's
what it was we have to call Mary
Elizabeth and she'll know here's how I
always feel well I'm not invited to the
Oscars or the Emmys or anything so why
the [ __ ] would I go to any of these
things and and Melissa says because it's
good you meet people it's good and she's
right she meets people and I see people
I know yeah and that's you know that's
not telling us
they tend to be very yes they're very
fun you meet someone you find out
they're a fan and it's fun it's good
yeah yeah it's nice it's nice but you
also meet someone and you say that
you're a fan and they seem like not so
interested well that sucks yeah that's a
bummer yeah yeah that's a bummer you
know like at this point like
oh well
um
oh Christ there goes the brain people oh
we've been writing all day though
Matthew Broderick Matthew Broderick
Matthew Broderick
are you oh no I haven't did you ever run
in with Broderick I did we were at uh
SNL's 40th anniversary party and that
was a fun night everybody who's everyone
was there except you guys and uh well
this is a this is why 40th that was a
while ago yeah this was a while ago like
10 years ago yeah like something like
that now yeah I'm like there's Matthew
Broderick I'll say hi I'll say hello
sure and he's kind of blowing me off
like I'm just like some fan and he's
blowing me off he's not being a dick but
he's also like you know really not
engaging me and uh just at one point I
go just so you know uh I'm a person of
value
he said that yeah
yeah
I've never told you the story no yeah
and that stuff and God's attention and
he laughed did he laugh yeah yeah he
laughed and then we we chatted for a
minute but I don't know why I I don't
know it just seems weird for a guy who
literally just told us that he goes to
these parties and only talks to people
that he knows for you to be not only
trying to talk to Matthew Broderick but
being so insistent upon it that you
would say something to him like just so
you know well and I know you were joking
but yeah well yeah I'm joking but like
after probably because yeah I don't feel
like I have great interactions at those
things and then I would probably just
like ah [ __ ] it man come on yeah [ __ ]
off man talk to me for a second
and that was good he was lovely it was
it was fun is that because you're a big
Matthew Broderick fan were you excited
to talk to him Matthew Broderick what do
you what are you what are your favorite
Matthew election
oh yeah he's great in the election great
movie and he's great in it yeah Far East
biola's day off
yeah the French film that's a good one
um yeah and others
we are back with a brand new year of
podcasts and thus a brand new year of
ads yes a brand new year of Brands there
you go and what better way to kick it
off than uh being supported by our good
friends at hey athletic greens athletic
greens is back yeah that's right now
maybe some of you are just tuning in for
the first time maybe your New Year's
resolution was to listen to that always
sunny podcast that everybody everybody's
talking about in which case you haven't
heard us talk about athletic greens
before or their delicious green powder
ag1 yeah well shout out to you okay
first time creeper listener and boy man
are you got you are in for a treat
literally it is a treat because it
tastes so good and ag-1 is a product I
literally use every day with one scoop
you're getting 75 high quality vitamins
minerals Whole Food Source superfoods
probiotics and adaptogens think about
how good your body will feel with all
that support that is a body that just
won't quit to make it easy athletic
greens is going to give you one free
year supply of immune supporting vitamin
D and five free travel packs with your
first purchase all you have to do is
visit athleticgreens.com Sunny you want
the stuff you know go get go get it
there yeah get it there you know again
that is athletic greens.com Sunny to
take ownership of your health and pick
up the ultimate daily nutritional
insurance
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
it's help
but better betterhelp is an online
therapy service that allows you to talk
to a licensed professional from anywhere
you choose you can even switch
therapists whenever you feel like it
I've used better help before and it was
great it's super convenient that it's
online so I can take calls from wherever
I am I could even take one from the
podcast studio if I needed to we do have
good chairs for it yeah I probably
wouldn't want my therapy sessions
recorded though but you never know I
feel like what we do on the podcast
sometimes is kind of a form of therapy
you know but then again none of us are
none of us are licensed and that's
really what makes the difference here
right when you're talking to someone
who's an expert in what you've gone
through or or or are going through that
that that is truly invaluable all you
got to do is fill out a questionnaire on
betterhelp.com and get started plus
Sonny's Gonna Get You ten percent off in
2023 we're not just getting help we're
getting better health so if you want to
live a more empowered life therapy can
get you there visit betterhelp.com sunny
today and get 10 off your first first
month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash Sunny
[Music]
Charlie and I got into a fight
we got into well in the parking lot I
mean you were you when you had
Glenn no no not following no no no he
was trying to do a bet oh that wasn't
funny
um none of it's funny I was trying to
perpetuate the for yeah for the myth
yeah I find I find that's annoying
[Laughter]
making [ __ ] up and it's like
[ __ ] up hey [ __ ] facts what about
Greek myths you hate it just Campbell's
I don't know a fictional myth is fine oh
but being like you know Glenn was like
Crossing his leg uh all episode and I
think he might have testicular cancer oh
yeah that's like a conspiracy yeah yeah
yeah you're right yeah and there was a
lot of conspiracy theories yeah like
re-editing of like well what we're
talking about is slowly listeners we
were talking about the live episode that
we did
um
uh for the holidays to raise money for
charity and
um Charlie and Rob had a very like I
don't didn't think you guys well as a
matter of fact
that was if anyone thinks that that was
fighting that that's coming from someone
who has no ability to uh work through
confrontation in a healthy way that was
a I would say that that was a very
healthy
confrontational feels like too strong of
a word but but it was somewhat
confrontational in the sense that you
were
confronting Charlie about something an
issue that you have with him sometimes
when we're writing or when we're working
on the show and but that doesn't but
like there's so many negative
connotations that but it shouldn't it
shouldn't have to be that way we should
be able to have very honest and open
conversations about issues that we're
having with each other with each other
and do it in a way that's uh you know
productive but it didn't actually seem
like we were in a fight right it was it
was fun that when somebody re-edited
re-edited it to make it no I think it
was because we were argue arguing about
a creative point on filter which is much
more true to how the show works right
like although there was moves involved
but like oh yeah we have those arguments
all the time oh maybe I'm just so
desensitized I have those kinds of
conversations with almost everybody in
my life I know but that's right now but
you are you are unique in that regard
but you guys have those arguments with
each other and have what you guys have
those same kind of arguments with each
other I'm sure I have them with you as
well we have I have them with Meg all
the time yeah no I've not had an
argument with you're like that but no
no it's coming you know what I mean
I feel like it's you know what I mean
it's on it's right on the precipice
right on the tip of our no I don't like
I mean honestly that wasn't even an
argument it was like you saying the
thing that you think is important
Charlie's saying the thing he thinks is
important neither of you were asking the
other person to change you know just
like said things like and I think you're
dead wrong now to most people to most
people that comes off as extremely
confrontational and negative to Rob
that's just like I'm telling you how I
feel I'm not saying I'm right yeah and
that's the difference is that is that if
you're saying you are dead wrong and I
know I'm right that to me is the
difference between it being healthy and
unhealthy when you say if somebody says
in a creative conversation like this is
what I think and you think this way and
I have to say I think you're dead wrong
but as long as the openness to finding
out that I'm actually the one that's
dead wrong is is there and I think it's
a healthy confrontation as long as
you're willing to you're never yeah
that's the thing I don't know if you
could ever have a conversation with
somebody and not express the way you
feel or you're just lying people are you
kidding me dude I think though like just
because there's like a little booze
involved that had a little bit less of
the breaks that would normally have you
know what I mean like it we would have
the same conversation
it would just maybe down one peg
and Aiden would be out of seven yeah but
like but you didn't say that story when
you were saying yeah
to a degree that I think the average
person would be very uncomfortable
around somebody they've known for 20 no
no no dude people I guess people go
through entire marriages for 40 years
without really I can't wrap my head
around that no neither can I by the way
I'm with you I'm 100 I think I think
Charlie and I could do it like just
avoid conflicts that much
and I think that we and I think you know
look I avoid it a little bit I don't
think I avoid it quite as much as you do
but I will say that we used to avoid it
more yeah I think I'm pretty good now it
just being like hearing the information
taking a second with it and then just be
like no I think this you know but that
was a that took a while to develop I
think in the beginning I would avoid it
like it's a yeah because it can be
uncomfortable it's like it's it's hard
and you feel that like you feel your ego
right you say something to me like you
say something to me like I think you're
dead wrong about this there's always
going to be this little part of me that
that ego part of me that goes that goes
what the [ __ ] does this guy think he is
[ __ ] this guy like he's but how dare he
[ __ ] say that to me I'm dead [ __ ]
wrong like that's [ __ ] you know but
then I go but then I go oh no that's
just my ego like he's saying he thinks
I'm dead wrong that's just his opinion
he is entitled to his opinion who the
[ __ ] am I to say that he's not entitled
to that opinion I can argue my point and
I can try to convince you how and why
I'm not dead wrong you know but I should
also confront the possibility that maybe
I am dead wrong
but so that's how we always do and
anytime we have a discussion like that
is we have a post discussion afterwards
right like a follow-up which we did do
the next day which was like I think I
was thinking this I think you were
thinking this I think we were thinking
this in the room and this is why we're
feeling this way which is why we've
worked together for
I mean 16 Seasons but 20 years yeah and
uh yeah 20 years this year actually uh
2003 yeah 2003 the fall of 2003 was when
we shot the very first version of the
home movie yeah buddy wow yeah buddy so
this smart this will Mark the 20th year
of us working together you guys gonna do
anything we should special a little
something with each other yeah we
probably won't but we should all right
well should we talk about the mortgage
episode yes I don't know I want to talk
about Brian Unger in this episode Ryan
on your man is so damn a lot of good
actors in this episode like BJ Byrne
Works PJ all the time as a burger
is that the dad of the um family that
owns the house yeah no oh it's the it's
the guy we're set we want to sell the
house he's the guy he freaks out with
the honey honey and vinegar scene yes
yeah we can Scorsese movies and stuff
like he works
who we did the pilot of boldly going
nowhere with he was the lead of our uh
our our pilot uh very funny man oh and
he plays the um husband of the couple
that's buying Dee's baby correct yes the
great Melanie lynskey yeah I feel like
needs no description everyone knows who
Melanie is yeah they were super funny
so sorry but do you have any history
with drugs or alcohol never neither
great she is so good I I'm gonna throw
in a plug for Melanie lynskey for a
second here she did a movie that I
believe won Sundance one year
uh it was bought by Netflix
and it kind of flew under the radar it
was a movie called I don't feel at home
in this world anymore
and if you guys have not seen that movie
it is fantastic it's her and Elijah Wood
and Christine Woods is that her name
wait yeah the mother of mine of Dennis's
child she's she's incredible in the
movie
um it's a threat it was made by Megan
Blair made by uh the great Macon Blair
who's uh incredible writer and director
anyway if you haven't seen the movie
it's great and if you guys have not seen
the movie you should check it out it's a
lot of fun it's really really it's very
Cohen Brothers it's really really funny
but it's also a thriller and it's dark
and it's kind of gruesome in moments and
there's action but it's also super funny
have you seen things requests
have I seen what Mythic Quest Mr Quest
what is this have you seen welcome to
wrexham
I'm just wondering about you you're
talking about these don't I don't want
to use it in the movies that no one's
ever heard of and you're given Melanie
plugs for them but you've never seen
anything by the way not just me Megan
also works on Charlie created the show
you've never seen it I've seen as many
episodes of Welcome to wrexham as you
have of AP Bio untrue how many episodes
of AP Bio have you seen 10. I mean I've
seen and I've okay I've seen eight
episodes of Mythic Quest so I'm almost
there how many of wrexham
because that's what you started with I
that's what I know he was talking about
it you just said I've seen as many it
doesn't matter he was talking about
Mythic quests the other day in the room
and complimenting uh it specifically
David oh well I was David fighting his
performance uh in the show I think the
show is uh I think it's fantastic I do I
just uh you're right listen it's fair
it's fair it's fair part of it part of
it is that I can't get Jill to watch
anything with me and there are things
that she wants to watch together but
then I can't so then I but so then I'm
like feel and that Rob's things no I'm
saying we don't watch anything together
anymore we want because our kids never
go to bed anymore
it's a high class product can you
imagine when we started the show that
there would come a point in time where
we were fortunate and privileged enough
to be in the situation where we're doing
so much work that we had not seen each
other's [ __ ] I think about that all the
time actually because well then we were
first getting started and we would have
people in our friend group that would
get a job
oh yeah a movie or a TV show would be a
huge deal and now yeah people are just
now everybody's working which is great
did they get the heat there it feels
like they got the heat the heat is
turned back on today was the first day
that we had heat in this building so
there's been we are on a major studio
Line yeah in the middle of the
atmospheric River yeah a week and a half
it took for them to turn their heat back
on yes I mean we were like huddled
around people are gonna put my sticky
sweater today because I was like it's
gonna be like I could already imagine
the creeps and the and the and the and
the listeners already jumping on top of
us for complaining about how cold it is
in our office because we're in
California it was 58 degrees it was
freezing in my eyes
that's cool yes that's cold for an
interview that's L.A gold yes no but
first
58 degrees if you're in an office
building in like North Dakota this time
of year you're like 58 degrees let's go
to the beach okay well yes if you're
outside but again 58 degrees in your
office when you're just sitting there at
your desk that's cold even in North
people were wearing even in the winter
hats and [ __ ] well just for those people
in in The Dakotas then we'll stop
complaining about that and and I really
do want to talk about Brian Unger just
because I was watching this episode and
realizing that he occupies such a funny
space which is like he is a straight man
to you guys but not really like he like
he like Charlie comes in to threaten him
to ask to challenge him to a duel and he
accepts like immediately immediately
if it isn't the big time Hot Shot lawyer
man oh my God I do not have time for you
yeah so we both have busy schedules so
I'll make this quick
a shadman's words with you for long I am
challenging you sir to a duel I accept
are you serious now accept your
challenge that's the funniest scene in
the whole episode that's not straight
man funny man that's too funny man you
know he really is
it's like I almost start to become the
straight man as he becomes the aggressor
and that's well you're the antagonist
coming in and then he turns antagonist
like yeah he's really really good it was
so funny and he's talking about putting
one between your teeth and it popping
out the back of your head and Charlie
you're just covering your mouth like in
the it's such a good act break too it's
like such a good like uh-oh little known
fact Brian Unger was on the original
Daily Show yep he's the original Daily
Show before Jon Stewart when it was
Craig Craig Gilmore yeah he was one of
the correspondents he's one of the
original correspondents and was super
duper funny on there we have to talk
about Vic Vinegar and Hugh honey from
this episode this is the birth of them
correct well it's birth and death
birthday
I think one and done with those no
because you brought you call yourself
Vic Vinegar again when you're playing a
bodyguard yes
stuff but maybe Hugh honey doesn't come
back in that and I tell him that he's
washed I'm like you're washed up vinegar
or something like that right like you
got no you got no uh follow through I
can't remember what I said that
storyline is so bizarre it's like you
just announced you're gonna do a good
real estate good realtor bad realtor
military thing and then we just watch it
how fast
uh culminating a line of Mac saying I
should take your wife upstairs and show
her what it's like to be deep inside a
really big house how about I take your
wife upstairs and show what it's like to
be deep inside a really big house what
what
it doesn't make any sense yeah no but
there's some there's something good
about like being young enough to not
feel as though we need to justify it
more you know like well the funniest say
you didn't because the fans love it yeah
Funny's funny and if you think this
episode is not that good I would say
you're out of touch and you're dead
wrong uh us all coming together at the
house
felt zany yeah like silly we didn't need
to do it you mean when we come over and
Bash the door in no that's great with
the end at the end yeah like we need to
get to I need a place to hide and I
don't know I liked you guys all ending
up in the pool don't buy the house Frank
doesn't want to buy the house yeah he
thinks he thinks that we're we're we're
merging the baby in the house thing so
we're gonna yeah
something we came up with on the day
like we had a different no ending
scripted and we're like I think no I
think that was in the script yeah I
actually liked it coming back because
you announced at the beginning should we
merge the ideas and then you end up
merging them which I think is kind of
funny satisfying oh yeah yeah good yeah
yeah yeah
that's why we talked about it we wanted
to seem smarter yeah honey they made a
merge reference and then they did merged
not but I'm sure that is why we did it
yeah the stunt of the uh of Jack Knights
yeah that that was a stun that was a
stunt person watch me bust out this
sweet jackknife
[Music]
I've never seen before or since a stunt
person they're always I mean they they
really throw themselves like 100 into
everything they do and they always want
another take and they're always like
obviously very safe but still they want
another take because they want to get it
better and you gotta kind of rein them
in and be like we got it that was the
first time I'd ever seen a stunt person
go did you get it and we were like yeah
we think we got it and she's like good
we're like do you want another take and
she's like no she's like no that's
because there is no way to fake that you
just legit you got to take it you just
gotta take it you gotta take it
Indigo yeah that is a belly flop yeah
and she hit it hard yeah
he has had probably the best stunt
performances like amazing people work
for I like we except a lot of them are
her yeah well she she as well has done
great things but she's also had great
women working with her doing some
incredible stuff yeah and the double was
great it absolutely looks like it's her
no you can't stop doing that no was that
a stunt double of you guys kicking
through the door from the other side I
love that bit that you were gonna Ram
the door from one side and then you
don't get to so then you decide to Ram
it from the inside out yeah and then
there's like a lot of kicking it that
you guys are doing you know I said I've
never kicked in it that was us I said
I'd never kicked in the door before yeah
but it's not quite well through it it's
just that door you know and kicking
through yeah and it was and it wasn't
but it wasn't a set I remember that was
a whole thing because Breakaway doorway
it was a break we had to take the door
off of the hinges and put a fake put a
fake door if you look closely there's
actually some mismatches of where the
brakes are throughout the episode but
there's also in that scene another fly
that's buzzing above Charlie's head when
he's talking to the lawyer let me handle
this Frank it's not bad
I'm well educated well versed I know
that situation is like this real estate
wise they're very complex actually
they're pretty simple the forms are all
standard boilerplate
okay well we're all hungry we're gonna
get to our hot plate soon enough all
right no let's say you and I go
toe-to-toe and bird law and see who
comes out to Victory you know I don't
think I'm gonna do anything
um close to that and I can see clearly
you know nothing about the law it seems
like you have a tenuous grasp on the
English language in general okay well
filibuster
now just to be clear to digitally take a
fly out of a shot is so cheap and so
easy because it's just like a few frames
what was it in 2009 100 yeah let's go
back
I mean as I pointed out we didn't even
put a sound effect in when that when
when we go through the door and the
freaking battering ram lands on the
ground there's no sound effect yeah no
clang clang nothing just
oh that one got missed yeah yeah yeah
yeah like they destroyed like whole
planets and movies years before we were
born and it looked realistic you know
they can take a fly out of a out of a
show in 2009 that's right but I didn't
want to take the flies out it looks
makes it looks real yeah because it
gives it more life Rob thinks you're
dead wrong I think you're dead wrong I
think what happens is it takes you not
enough flies and mythical
that's your problem right yes I think
that's why I'm not responding
[Laughter]
it takes you out of it and so far as
Megan noticed that there was a fly if
you notice that there's a fly somewhere
why wouldn't there be a fly though yeah
because it's on TV yeah speaking of
flies
um my son asked about teleportation and
he's like what can we can people do that
yet and I was like no but maybe
eventually one day but it's kind of an
amazing potential technology where it it
basically takes you down to an atomic
level sends that information somewhere
and then rearranges all the atoms and he
was like well that's cool I'm like yeah
but what happens just imagine this if
while you're there a fly
comes into the chamber with you wait he
pitched you the plot of the flight
yeah no no this is great your kid is a
genie I pitched it to him
and he was like what what would happen I
was like well on the other end you would
be part man and part fly and he was like
coolest thing I've ever heard and I'm
like well what do you think would happen
and he was like
man you'd like probably eat a bunch of
[ __ ] and I was like yeah well son let me
show you yeah and uh but like you become
very attractive to women here's the VHS
somehow you become more viral
for a minute and then it takes a turn it
takes a bit of a turn yeah when you're
at the coffee shop with the with your
your lovely lady that uh you know you've
become much more masculine for her and
then you you know pour the entire thing
of sugar in your coffee that's where
that's where it took that's not really
where it takes to turn I can't remember
it it's been a long time since I've seen
it last night I drove over over a cold
water Canyon in the rain oh
um because that's where my really
raining scary yeah
scary am I sketchy big time like the
amount of water that was just gushing
down the side of the hills yeah yeah oh
right you gotta yeah it's like a street
named Cold Water Canyon yeah I mean it
kind of rain I was warned you were
warned
right yeah you didn't listen I was on my
way to see I'm gonna talk about it Mr
John Bryan uh who's scoring uh the movie
that I directed and had been working on
for so many years and I love this dude's
work he is incredible but anyway it was
a scary scary drive over there such a
talented guy yes and in fact we were
scoring a scene that you happen to be in
spoiler alert
um but uh is that like awakens something
in you of like some Primal like getting
home through like a storm and like you
know that sort of no I was just like I
don't know that I want to die like
listening to smartless
you know it's better to die listening to
smartless than to die listening to your
own podcast yeah imagine if you were
yeah like you know you're dead you know
and like you're all mangled and but the
stereo's still going yeah and it's pot
and it's the sunny podcast
really I got to a really hectic point I
really like where the water was really
coming down I thought you met a hectic
and smartless I was like I don't think
that was good but I was at the I was on
the ad and uh Sean was reading some ad I
didn't want to listen to and I was like
I can't look at my phone to skip the ad
because I really gotta Focus to get
through this little hairy part here and
I was like but I don't want to have the
hairy thing happen while I'm listening
to the ad it would have been fine in the
regular part of the the episode but not
reasonable thoughts yeah speaking of
bats
[Music]
hey you guys know what happened to me
the other day uh you guys ever been on
the go and you know just not had time
for like a full meal yeah whatever
happened to you is that ever happen to
you yeah that's like an extremely common
occurrence that's why I'm glad that uh
we're supported by huel today okay
because it helped me out in a pinch you
know and it's an easy and delicious way
to get a healthy meal when I can't slow
down to eat right that's because uh with
hula you don't eat you drink cool Black
Edition is a high protein nutritionally
complete meal in a convenient shake that
means it has everything your body needs
in Two Scoops including 27 vitamins and
minerals and 40 grams of protein that's
right and heal black is vegan
gluten-free lactose free it's got no
GMOs palm oil or artificial sweeteners
you know plus it comes in delicious
flavors that taste like cake oh man cake
I had so much cake over the holidays let
them drink cake let them have their cake
and drink it too yeah or just drink the
fuel because that's all your body needs
go to fuel.com Sunny to get a free tea
shirt and Shaker with your order that's
h-u-e-l-.com sunny and get a free shirt
and Shaker with your order
[Music]
go to Turbo Tax and don't do your taxes
meet with an expert who will do them for
you Turbo Tax experts can relieve you
from the stress of taxes and file for
you so you can do not taxes
show your eyes things that are not taxes
unpack a moving box of not taxes taste
not taxes sing not taxes a lullaby hope
not taxes sleeps through the night grab
a saddle and ride not taxes into the
sunset with Turbo Tax an expert will do
your taxes from start to finish ensuring
your taxes are done right
guaranteed so you can relax feels good
to be done with your taxes doesn't it
come to Turbo Tax and don't do your
taxes visit turbotax.com and learn more
Intuit TurboTax full service products
only video meeting while expert does
your taxes required see guarantee
details at turbotax.com
guarantees that's with an S guarantees
you guys got any any New Year's
resolutions
no
I didn't do that this year I've tried it
in the past but
I didn't either I didn't either I make
resolutions all year old are you all
yeah
he's given up already he's resolved to
finish the sentence or you're gonna give
it up my mouth did not my mouth it
wasn't my it was my mouth that gave up
my mouth gave up and then my body was
like well you just [ __ ] do it mouth
really and then I just then my whole
body gave up and I was like what about
you Jesus set up for you did you set up
I mean I yeah yes but my my resolutions
are only in place to
for shame uh because uh Catholic [ __ ]
yeah like where I will because I'm like
you I mean I we're all trying all year
trying to do exactly trying to better
set goals for myself and so what I find
is I make I set a goal and then my goal
this year was a very simple one which
was to stop complaining so much just
stop [ __ ] complaining just whenever I
feel like I want to complain just be
more grateful because a it doesn't get
you what you want B it just makes you
look and feel like a piece of [ __ ] just
be grateful and uh man it's hard yeah
yeah I feel like you I might have
doubled down part of the problem with
with resolutions and sometimes it feels
like you actually go the opposite
direction yeah and do it more so
um but right it makes it makes it you
create a stigma yeah then it becomes
even more appealing yeah but but I will
say that if you if you do at least make
some kind of internal Proclamation that
um you hold yourself maybe a little bit
more accountable so I find myself maybe
complaining maybe just as much I don't
know but then I'm going well I think
that's a noble it's a noble goal right
it's so it's good I mean that's the
right that's the Eckhart toll I mean
that's the first step right is
recognizing it when you're doing it yeah
observing it
so good on you good on you I did I did
have one this wasn't a New Year's
resolution but I I did lay down a
challenge to my uh to two of my nephews
I've got three three nephews my sister's
got three boys they're older
um my 18 year old nephew and my 22 year
old nephew
I challenged them to a pull-up contest
now I'm 46. I'm about to turn 47. and I
told those boys I was like don't let me
beat you in this pull-up contest but now
I'm determined to to be there's an 18
year old in the mix yeah
he's strong but he's big he's heavy so
much energy I'm not saying he's fat he's
big you know so I don't know but but the
other the 22 year old is a little a
little leaner and he's been hitting the
gym a lot
you know so I was like how many people
should be a good challenge
is that hand forward or uh yeah and I'm
a traditional like wide grip okay
um I'm probably at uh 14. wow oh that's
good I'm very impressed it's very good
it's pretty good it's pretty I can't do
one well it's not bad he's been you've
been doing it with with like weights
tied too I haven't been doing that I've
just you know so that's that's I'm
training for it okay because uh I said
that we gotta we gotta get ourselves no
touching the ground feet don't touch
down oh no no no no no no no all the way
up I go chin Over the Bar nah I go to
mouth I go to mouth
in a way that I feel like is kind of
negative I think that's high enough so I
didn't do any gym resolutions but my
resolution was based on something I
started doing at the gym which is that
my trainer started telling me when I
would like uh because I would lift to
the point where I like failed you know
couldn't lift whatever I was lifting and
she would always say like good job you
failed and I was like that's just not
like for me that doesn't work that
doesn't compute but then I realized like
no that's like that should be the new
motto for 2023 is like trying and
failing at stuff and then feeling good
about the fact that you failed something
yeah because that means you're like
pushing yourself and it doesn't feel
good to hear that no it doesn't but I
but I kind of am like in a place where
I've got to get used to it because I'm
like trying so many new things and if I
keep letting like every failure just
rock me I'm never gonna like what a
great metaphor though but like the
reason you built you build muscles
because your muscle is failing that's
right and the only way that you can grow
is if you actually take yourself to that
place
yeah got to be willing to fail to grow
so that is a very good metaphor yeah so
something that a trainer who would often
do this thing where you know let's say
we're doing something like 20 reps and
we would go he would go up to 10 right
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten and then he would start going
down nine eight seven six and it was
kind of like counting down right
and I found that psychologically I was
like that I was like I had to tell him
finally I was like you know what when
you count down it saps my energy I don't
like a countdown I need you to be
counting up all the way you've got to go
to the Stars I will also break
accountancy like psychologically I'll
break counts into little smaller sets if
I'm doing 15 I do five five and five
exactly yes I did hey yes I do hey man
no wonder you've been working because
then I'm like I only have to get to five
and then I only have to get to five and
then I only have to get the five yes we
should hang out
dude we should hang out
foreign